these are the most locals you ever seen
already
no critic there's so much more of this
move that you don't even get no critic
Great Scott Barney no critic okay yes
critic again I haven't decided I am
unclear about all of this hello big hand
going to cometh but no hello yes somos
are you gonna move the camera a blowjob
there dude again but I do it don't you
want to truly enjoy this movie you have
to give yourself to this movie you must
give yourself to the movie you have to
give yourself to the movie I got
whatever why cuz it was crash your eyes
okay come you you see you see do you see
you see what more do you want to stay
alive you see all right that can be a
problem sometimes but there's so much
more awesomeness to this movie that
you're not good yeah I just got like the
light but there's so much more awesome
this this movie contains like what your
mama oh but there's still so much more
also miss to this movie that it contains
shit alright well just contain shape and
espisode ah quiet moment take it off
screen
oh quit it but don't you see I don't see
um because it's her dream what I'd ring
it yes
hey that last clip was to her okay I
take issue with that sir
hey that last clip okay okay face trip
good news everyone
hey that last clip was from milk money
you always do new actually it's like
damn that's really funny okay hey that
last clip was from milk money got it
okay okay professional all right well my
balls are alive with the sound of
Whoopie you fool
oh oh I guess I'm just kind of an ya
know she is I was thinking it pretty
loudly perhaps what we need is a mind
even more than their go to combat it you
talking about I'll show you a fluid
cavalry flu beef laughs was that it what
we need is a mind even more cynical to
combat it it is Halloween is awful moon
come on critic the water in the we'd
like a Moulin Rouge pool is fine Oh
okay but we're gonna talk about this can
we pick a better location
I feel like if I had your back go back
over I feel like that sometimes - all
right but okay sorry I'm sorry critic I
had no choice
no choice where's I have a gun boom hey
I seem to have Worf just to some
convention of some kind dad right off I
did oh oh it seemed to be in Disneyworld
for some reason good mm-hmm
maybe watchful a road where and when
take you sit yeah now tell us yes tell
us
Oh
on me it's nice
okay shut up please okay shot please
okay shut up please
didn't I spit on you I'm sorry it's the
target hey wouldn't you trust a guy hey
wouldn't hey Stewie um yeah no that's
right I got his green play-doh it's
interest stories to do a story but then
he sings Whitney Houston song and she's
total puddi in his panties panties yeah
don't I thought men were Hayes yeah well
at least I do I mean I don't know about
him he might be weird I'm not my own but
is but then he sings Whitney Houston
song at her and she's total putty in his
hands
and pads okay it's okay finals like
where does the putty go
I'll show you sometime I guess despite
the fact that they try to avoid him
every chance that they get
I was like who and relax
yeah I can't sit up straight too long no
longer the corset yeah okay same big
deal she's prostituted herself for years
and now she suddenly can't sleep with
this guy but good now why is this a big
deal
she's prostituted herself for years and
now she so I'm sorry I was fucking
around shut up I like that haha penis
shut up I like that one ha ha penis damn
we're never getting it through this way
okay okay shut up I like that one haha a
penis well look just because she's a
whore doesn't mean she's a horrible
person I try not to make eye contact I
it looks like several penises that's
what's so funny like that one is easy no
no I see that one but they all sort of
look like penises
maybe I'm just really sick every child I
see on the street was like a penis that
bird Peters that's now a vagina but that
flower penis
Zoidberg watching that Moulin Rouge
movie the best DVD I own it's the only
DVD ayob do you think they'd let a
character reveal such a important plot
devices you didn't have a name okay what
is it Marilyn okay what is it Berlin and
besides okay what is it Marilyn
and besides okay did you crack that's
bullshit you liked this scene I do not
it's it's stupid turn it how can you not
with two such well-dressed Madri oh dear
we got bald and balding admit it critic
even you can not admit how tonight okay
don't bet this movie it's open
everything in it is stupid I just saw
her looking rising hi Lindsey
I know please marry me take your vows in
that please hey it's novel of a guess
mmm father
oh god that voice kills me
I'm so glad were you a similar if you
can I hear turn a little more to the
side I'm totally using that so then he's
like got this like oh my god they're
gonna see my ball heavy breathing you're
almost getting to like a a Miss Piggy
thing I do anything to record walk into
a cross are high no I kept like you say
like well I put you in my lame is thing
after you wind your way into it when do
you take an offense of that now this is
actually how I got my first singing
cameo basically I was whining on Twitter
okay fine I'll include you how's my
Kubrick face well of course it doesn't
make any sense
love doesn't make any sense singing in a
movie doesn't make any sense you me like
it doesn't make any sense maybe not that
heavy breathing what is it about this
movie that drives you absolutely insane
sorry yeah I hate my life myself okay I
paid my heart yeah yeah she's your whore
yeah bees just like that's that's
vengeance man that's getting up in front
of an audience and paying her just to
make her feel bad that's not love that's
high school did
happen to you in high school during any
someone golf and said I paid Annie my
horn have a flashback this happening no
it's a hard-knock life I'm pretty who
Billy I'm a whore Fionn now let it go
woman let it go
patriarchy if you're gonna say that I'm
not gonna call you woman because I
didn't write that better not lay a
finger on my Butterfinger